WORSE THAN I THOUGHT.
THANK BOTH OF YOU FOR COMING ON.
WE'RE JOINED BY COUNSELOR TO THE
PRESIDENT KELLYANNE CONWAY.
I WANT TO PLAY THE CHALLENGES WE
SAW DOWN AT THE BORDER LAST
WEEK.
>> WE HAVE TO REMOVE FROM THE
FIELD PATROL BOTTLES, AND MANY
OF US ARE PARENTS.
WE KNOW HOW TO CHANGE DIAPERS
AND WE KNOW HOW TO FEED BOTTLES.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> WASHINGTON.
>> Laura: THIS GOES ON "YOU
TUBE," FIGURED OUT HOW TO CRAWL,
RELEASED WITHIN 24 HOURS.
AFTER SEEING THIS, MY INSTINCT
IS TO SAY DEAL AND FOCUS ALL OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S RHETORIC ON
THAT?
DAN IS RIGHT, IT IS A RAGING
FIRE AT THE BORDER, FIRE OF
HUMANITY ENDANGERING THEMSELVES
AND OUR COUNTRY.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
I'M NOT GETTING THAT.
>> THERE'S TWO POINTS TO THE
PRESIDENT'S BIG PROPOSAL, FULL
AND FINAL BORDER SECURITY, WHICH
HE'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR FOUR
YEARS HE'S BEEN RUNNING FOR AND
BEING.
.
THE SECOND PART IS THE
MODERNIZATION AND MERIT-BASED
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
YOU AT LEAST WENT DOWN TO THE
BORDER.
THE.
'S PLAN DOLLS THE SAME THING.
HE'S TALKING TO THE
PROFESSIONALS 59 THE BORDER,
WHAT DO THEY NEED.
HE'S NOT BOTHERING WITH THE
PEOPLE IN CONGRESS.
THEY FAIL TO ACT.
THEY CAN JUST FIX THINGS SO THAT
WE, THE COURT DECISIONS THAT,
COMPELS TO US RELEASE KIDS AFTER
0 DAYS.
WE HAVE NO OPPORTUNITY OTHER TON
DO THAT.
THEY CAN FIX IT.
BUT THEY FAIL TO ACT.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS TAKING IT
ON.
THIS IS FULL AND FINAL BORDER
SECURITY.
YOU HAVE ONE MILLION PEOPLE
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY.
NOW, THIS YEAR.
ILLEGALLY.
AND I THINK WHEN SOME PEOPLE
CATCH AND RELEASE MAY NOT BE
AWARE CATCH AND RELEASE MEANS
INTO THE INTERIOR, NOT TO THEIR
HOME COUNTRY.
FOR YEARS THE FLOW WAS SINGLE
MALES FROM MEXICO, THEY COULD BE
RETURNED TO THEIR HOME COUNTRY.
NOT ALLOWED TO DO THAT NOW WITH
THE FLOW OF CHILDREN AND ADULTS.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
THIS PLAN.
I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF GOOD
STUFF IT IN.
>> TWO BIG THINGS.
>> Laura: WHAT IS THE PRIMARY
LEGISLATION.
>> IT WOULD BE IF WE COULD GET
THE DEMOCRATS TO READ THE PLAN
AND COME AND TALK TO US ABOUT
IT.
THIS PRESIDENT WANTS FULL AND
FINAL BORDER SECURITY, ALL OF
THE LOOPHOLES AT THE BORDER,
CLOSE THEM, GIVE THE BORDER
AGENTS WHAT THEY'VE BEEN ASKING
FOR, MORE TECHNOLOGY, THE
BARRIER, THE WALL, WE WILL HAVE
ABOUT 400 MILES OF IT CON, EVEN
THE NEWSPAPERS ARE SAYING THAT.
"WASHINGTON POST"-ABC POLL
REPORTED 17% INCREASE AMONG
DEMOCRATS FROM JANUARY WHEN
CHUCK AND NANCY SAID MANUFACTURE
A CRISIS TO APRIL, CALLING IT A
CRISIS NOW.
THEY'VE SEEN THE PICTURES.
BORDER SECURITY MEANS THAT,
CLOSING THE LOOPHOLES, HAVING
THAT BARRIER.
>> Laura: THAT YOU SAID CONGRESS
ISN'T GOING TO DO IT.
BLUMENTHAL, RICHARD BLUMENTHAL
FROM MY HOME STATE --
>> WHO CARES?
>> Laura: HE SAID IT'S
DESPICABLE DEMOGOGUERY.
IS THIS REALLY A 2020 PLATFORM
FOR ALL REPUBLICANS?
>> WE WOULD LOVE CONGRESS TO
COME TO THE WHITE HOUSE TOMORROW
AND FIND WAY TO ACT ON, THIS AT
LEAST READ IT.
THAT IS DISMISSIVE DEMOGOGUERY,
DOESN'T EVEN MATTER IF BLUMMEN
THOL THAT WILL ISN'T GOING TO
READ IT.
THIS IS NOT A 2020 DOCUMENT.
WE'RE INTERESTED IN 2019.
IN ADDITION TO FULL BORDER
SECURITY, IT MODERNIZES A SYSTEM
THAT HAS NOT BEEN TOUCHED SINCE
1965.
54 YEARS.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS CERTAINLY
ARE NOT TERM LIMITED BUT FRESH
AND LIMITED IDEAS FOR
IMMIGRATION WAS TERM LIMITED A
LONG TIME.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE THE STATUS
QUO.
THIS FOCUSES ON THE IMMEDIATE
FAMILY NOT JUST ADDING.
>> Laura: CAN YOU STILL SPONSOR
MINOR CHILDREN.
>> AND PARENTS, NO QUESTION.
>> Laura: WHY IS E-VERIFY, A LOT
OF US HOPED THE PRESIDENT TALKED
ABOUT THAT SO OFTEN, STEVEN
MILLER IS A BIG FAN, IF YOU STOP
THE EMPLOYMENT FOR THESE PEOPLE
THEY WON'T COME.
>> THIS IS TWO BIG FRONTS THAT
WE FELT COMFORTABLE PUTTING
FORWARD NOW, BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT SEES THE URGENCY AND
THE EXIGENCY OF BORDER SECURITY.
AND WE WANT TO SHINE A LIGHT
NOBODY IN CONGRESS HAS BOTHERED
TO TOUCH THE LEGAL IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM IN 54 YEARS.
THEY PRETEND THEY'RE WORRIED
ABOUT THE CHILDREN, PRESENT TEND
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
FAMILY.
IF THEY WERE, THEY WOULD DO
SOMETHING ABOUT GIRLS AT THE
AGES OF OUR BORDERS, PUMPED UP
WITH BIRTH CONTROL ON THE
TREACHEROUS JOURNEY, TESTED FOR
PREGNANCY.
IF THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT HAPPENS
TO THOSE KIDS ONCE THEY GET
HERE --
>> Laura: THE KIDS WERE
TRAUMATIZED.
>> OF COURSE THEY ARE, THEY COME
ON THAT JOURNEY WITH NO
GUARANTEE, LIED TO BY THE
COYOTES WHO TAKE THEIR LIFE
SAVINGS AND WORSE FOR MANY OF
THEM.
THE DEMOCRATS WANT IT AS 2020
ISSUE.
WE'D LIKE TO REVOLVE 234I9 2019.
>> Laura: ANY THOUGHT OF
REDUCING THE NUMBER, 1.1
MILLION, THE PRESIDENT RAN HARD
ON REEXAMINING THAT, STEVEN
MILLER WAS FOR LOWERING
IMMIGRATION, UNTIL WE GET THE
BORDER ISSUE SOLVED.
PAUSE IMMIGRATION, EXCEPT FOR
EXTREME CASES.
>> THIS IS MERIT BASED, IN THIS
COUNTRY 12% OF OUR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION COMES FROM
EMPLOYABILITY.
66% COMES FROM FAMILY TIES.
FLIP IT, CANADA HAS IT FLIPPED.
NEW ZEALAND HAS IT FLIPPED.
WE'RE LOOK AGENT A SYSTEM MORE
ALIGNED WITH OTHER COUNTRIES
WHO, YES, WELCOME IMMIGRANTS.
ALSO, THIS RIDICULOUS RAISE THE
WAGE ARTIFICIALLY OR GET MINIMUM
WAGE.
RAMENT IS $22.
>> Laura: DON'T LET THEM FLOOD
THE COUNTRY WITH MORE PEOPLE.